Should we still send pictures? Should we still submit test results? Can you still
people see people one-on-one? Yes, you can still send pictures. We do put them
in your file. Should you still send submit test results? You certainly can submit test
results. Do you see people one-on-one? No, we can't see people one-on-one anymore.
Understand, I know this is frustrated for you times it by 10 and that's the
frustration that we're feeling. You can just be frustrated. I want you to be
frustrated. I just want you to be frustrated at the right people. Don't be
mad at us. We are exhausted and very sad about all what's happening. Having to
fight this many fronts, so please understand that. So you reviewed my
homocysteine results and recommended the methyl supplements, so my question is what am I
corrected? So the methylated supplements and your B vitamins will help reduce
homocysteine levels. So that's what you're trying to do is reduce the homocysteine
level in your blood. That's the whole purpose. So back to the should we still
send pictures? You can. Should you? No, you don't have to. You can if you want to.
Should you still send submit test results? You can, especially if you have a
question about a test that you want to ask the zoom call, but those all have to be
addressed on the zoom call. So you could send maybe would be better to send
just the abnormal findings in the zoom call question box, which is similar to this
blue question box at the bottom of every page of the member site, but it doesn't
say requested. I'll say it says send submit a question. So that would probably be
the better thing to do is just submit the abnormal findings. If you have a question
about it, like somebody has a question about alcohol and phosphatase tone here,
we'll get to it a couple of minutes. They just submitted it in the question box,
which I think would be more appropriate.